in the midst of an intellectual
Maelstrom Stephen T pantadosi brings
forth a seminal tree Ties That boldly
refutes the once unassailable Bastion of
chomsky's approach to language with the
inexorable rise of large language models
Stephen unveils how the erstwhile Titan
of linguistics is now apparently
engulfed by the tidal wave of
computational advancements machine
learning has apparently not only
subverted the generative framework but
also transcended its confines to achieve
the seemingly impossible to discover
grammar without resorting to the methods
that linguistic Orthodoxy seemed
indispensable Stephen's Coop De Grace
challenges the dismissive critiques of
Chomsky and his acolytes his unrelenting
defense of large language models as
Bonafide linguistic theories transcends
the facile caricatures of anything goes
and mere engineering revealing the true
potential of these models for advancing
our understanding of language or is it